let's jump right into it that's
interesting you're talking about like
the black lives matter stuff is way
like michael brown and trayvon martin
was the start of
what uh what it started uh black lives
matter so this breaking news we got
let's just do the breaking news first
because this is particularly relevant
kyle rittenhouse released from kenosha
county jail
after bond posted it's pretty
straightforward that's the story right
so you know but those little details
they say that the teen was fatally
charged with shooting two protesters in
kenosha
many of you probably know about this
this was in wisconsin he is no longer in
custody at the kenosha county jail a
spokesperson for the sheriff said in a
statement uh
kenosha county prosecutors charged
written house and uh of antioch illinois
with fatally shooting joseph rosenbaum
and anthony huber
during a protest over a police shooting
in august they've also charged him with
wounding a third man
gage grassroots redness faces multiple
counts including intentional homicide
and illegally possessing a gun
his attorneys contend he was acting in
self-defense the case has been a
rallying point for conservatives yeah we
don't need that stuff
they say in a phone interview with the
washington post rittenhouse revealed the
gun he used in the shooting was
purchased using money he received
from an unemployment check during the
coronavirus pandemic
basically his coveted stimulus check
used to buy a gun smart man
written i'd say i mean he's in a hot
he's in hot water right now but
right now 17 could not legally purchase
the weapon himself so he gave the money
to a friend to buy it for him according
to both written house and police reports
that's crazy that's messed up
he says i got my twelve hundred dollars
from the coronavirus illinois
unemployment
because i was on furlough from the ymca
i got my first unemployment check so i
was like oh i'll use it to buy it he
told the post
prosecutors have charged a wisconsin man
with supplying the gun that's crazy
and his interview with now said he
doesn't regret having the gun that night
saying i had to protect myself i would
have died that night if i didn't so
man i mean there's the breaking news
right off the bat i'd be interested to
hear what do you think about kyle
rittenhouse
i like kyle rittenhouse he's a hero wow
he's an american
hero it's a kid who took a stimulus
check
and bought guns yeah but he wasn't
legally allowed to and someone did it
illegally for him that's not cool that's
unconstitutional to put an age on
how old you can be to buy guns and it's
unconstitutional
there was a something recently came out
i can't remember exactly what it was but
they said
that there's a different like the
current supreme court is going to
interpret 2a very differently
i can't remember who i was talking about
this sure but they were like we might
start seeing a bunch of changes to
uh these laws that we got you know in
california they ruled
i think the ninth circuit ruled that uh
magazine size
you can't restrict that that's a
violation the second amendment so we'll
see if that
you know hits the rest of the country
yeah sticks but there was something like
somebody was telling me i can't remember
who they said that it's likely that with
the supreme court we're gonna start
seeing
the nitpicking of all these laws like oh
this thing can't be used but that thing
can't be used
that's going to go away yeah speaking of
unconstitutional
the inevitability of communism
is that what you think it's the
slithering dragon
it's the snake and it just
finds its way into your backyard and
bites your child when you're not looking
that's what it does
they're trying to bite us right now with
the vaccine and trying to take our guns
away they're trying to take our speech
away
that's what communism does man you know
but uh kyran house
is a hero in my eyes he stood up for
what he believed in
and looking at the video footage of the
shooting
i didn't see a guy purposely trying to
murder somebody
i saw somebody running for his life
saying he was going to the cops saying
he was going to the cops
indeed and there was a bit of a
verbal skirmish at the gas station prior
to
and one of the gentlemen who got his wig
split
he uh said go ahead shoot me mfr
this is what one of those guys said i
think that was rosenbaum wasn't it yes
yeah and then he chased after him
then he chased after him and he got
exactly what he asked for
um which is unfortunate yeah it's
unfortunate to have anybody lose their
life over
this political divide that the media has
created yep so you know shouts go to his
family and condolences to them
i just find it ironic that he asked for
it and he got it you know god speaks in
mysterious ways
but kyle rittenhouse i thought he was
defending himself
i think so i think that's clear i think
it's weird that they decided to do like
the harshest
possible charges imaginable to this kid
and then and then the media went nuts
just lying about everything yeah i heard
them call them everything from like
right wing to uh conspiracy
thank you white supremacist i'm like he
took out two other white dudes
and the third guy that got shot was
white it's it's it's
it's just it's the media game man and so
i talk to people all the time they have
no idea what happened
we had uh you know we had the the the
people that were actually on the ground
covering it
the riot squad okay so we had you know
like shelby talcott uh richie mcginnis
uh who else is in jorge ventura or
ventura that was one of those
someone else was no i think it was those
three those three yeah yeah they were
actually there watching it all happen
and i also talked to there were there's
a bunch of people that down there that
were covering it
the the rioters lit a dumpster on fire
and tried pushing it into a gas station
and that's what started it all so then
you get there's a video of kyle
rittenhouse running with a fire
extinguisher we don't
know exactly you have to talk to them
who are on the ground but basically him
and these dudes are trying to put these
fires out if they push a dumpster in a
gas station they blow it up that's going
to be real bad
oh yeah but because he did that they
attacked him
and that's the stuff that the media
doesn't talk about they just say you
know facebook
if you i guess if you praise him in any
way facebook like they ban you or
something like that or just
super strict yeah i wouldn't be
surprised if youtube comes after us over
the way we're talking about it
oh yeah let me calm down let me calm
down i mean look if it's
if if it's true it's true and if you
feel that way you feel the way it's i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna
lie i'm not gonna throw this kid under
the bus because the media's threatening
to ban me or social media says i'll ban
me
yeah we gotta tell people what really
happened well the only thing that i
would add to this conversation is that a
bunch of people agree with you
hotep because he raised two million
dollars for bail
that's crazy and i don't think that i
came out of his parents pocket that came
from people who really think that he
did it though they fundraised they
crowdfunded it yeah i truly believe that
to be the case
so what do you think about these riots
man so you know like kind of a segue
away from just the specific car written
house stuff we've had
a year of all this all these riots
things have kind of calmed down a little
bit but i think it's gonna
i think it'll light up again depending
what happens with trump but just in the
context of
you're saying you know the hotep thing
came out of black lives matter there was
like a split
so just your general thoughts man so i
have to give you a history on black
lives matter
that'd be important yeah yeah so that's
going to take us back to
uh what's that city darren seals
ferguson thank you
ferguson this is right outside of saint
louis right yeah yeah
it's part of the st louis county all
right so uh a brother by the name of
darren sills is a
community organizer out there and uh he
was he was right there with mike brown's
mom
you know the night after we shot you
know the whole nine through the whole
whole thing and uh the first night like
i always tell people with these things
the first night is usually very peaceful
it's people demonstrating they're upset
they're marching
they're venting right and then he said
that he saw some white kids pop up
and try to instigate with the police
they would pop up throw stuff at the
police and then disappear into the night
so we saw the precursor to antifa
basically
yeah and i was telling people at the
time that i was like hey you know
there's like
people that are infiltrating these
things
so he did a expose on black lives matter
and he exposed them talk about
you know how they came down with the
media a lot of people were taking credit
for his work and the organization that
he did and got those people out in the
streets
um and then uh you know he's talking
about those guys were cutting checks
they were sitting up in the house
donations were coming in and none of it
went to ferguson okay
it all went to people's pockets and
these big checks were coming to some of
these organizers so the organizers
getting paid
to just basically protest but none of it
went to the actual community
um and mysteriously he was murdered um
so you know i just liked every time i
talk about black lives matter history i
got a shout out darren sills
was he was either dude they found him in
the car or was that something yeah
that's crazy story man
yeah cause i i was down there a few days
after everything kicked off i was
i was in and out as the court case was
going on and then i remember hearing
a lot of people were pointing out that
some of the og activists were turning up
dead
yeah some people were saying as a grand
conspiracy i'm not saying that i'm just
saying that's
that's that happened to some people sure
as hell look like you
yeah i know yeah but that's tough man
how do you prove something like that
you know i don't i don't touch stuff
like that that's not my job um
i'm sure there's people out there that
that would risk their life to find out
the truth
i think we understand what happened out
there um i think a lot of us understand
the truth
of what happened to darren seals but um
you know repeated
darren says he was a soldier he was a
you know a true community leader he he
gave back his own money in his own time
to the community very important black
man
um and and if anybody you know who came
out to ferguson and stole money that was
terrible
that's terrible people do that i got a
quick i got a quick story for you man so
i was down there i can't remember which
night it was
but riots erupted a bunch of people
start running into
i think it was a dollar store across the
street i'm not sure smashing the windows
and then a bunch of young uh a bunch of
young dudes from ferguson linked arms
in front of the liquor store like that's
the one where michael brown went to
to stop the rioting and then i walked i
was i was standing right by there
there's another journalist
and this journalist from al jazeera
asked these guys like what are you doing
and they said the people riding in
destroying our community don't live here
they're coming from outside and they're
destroying everything they're burning
down our buildings
they're like we gotta we live here we
work here these are our stores why are
they doing this
and then what do we get from antifa
writing articles like in defense of
looting
yeah no joke that article became a book
apparently
and so i'm sitting there watching these
guys beg like please don't destroy
our home yeah and these other people
come in they're smashing up everything
and then these you know white
upper-class progressives
defend the the villains the people
destroying the community
they're defending themselves like i
always tell people anytime some of this
stuff happens
you have to understand that day one is
going to be looting and that that stuff
is is somewhat organic uh when you see
the fire
that's usually white antifa you know
what i mean like i always say i
always say you know black folks we might
be kleptomaniacs but
white folks is definitely pyromaniacs
yeah
that's my that's my running joke you
know but
when you see the fire usually that's
antifa
um and people try to identify that as
like black lives matter people say oh
they're burning down their own
neighborhood i'm like
no that's paid protesters and
antagonists that's
bolshevik money dude they're they're
they're like rich kids
who are bored yeah and i i dude i'll
tell you this man
i know some people who've got some legit
money
and it's not so much that the people
i've met in these things are i've never
seen anybody who's paid
to do anything like that right but i've
met people who are well off
and fund their friends to go out and do
that indeed
yeah indeed that's exactly what we see
happening here and
that's the problem with black lives
matter organization like my homie where
smith said
where the money at where the money at
there's some uh
high-profile activists people keep
asking where's money at
yeah where are where's the money where
did the money go over 100 million was
raised
i think in just one year alone so i know
they got a big bad sitting somewhere
that money never makes it to the
community that's what happens when you
deal with slimy democrats socialists and
marxists
[Laughter]
just don't mince words so you're right
so
like uh black lives matter was raising
money through thousand currents
do you know about that it's like they
were raising money through what i think
it's called thousand currents
it's a charity okay and so because black
lives matter didn't have their own
charity
right they used another but it but then
those donations are collected through
act blue
do you have the payment mechanism so you
had a lot of people saying that the
black lives matter was money would go
was going straight to joe biden
but it's not no but a percentage of all
that black lives matter money goes to a
fundraising platform for democrats
so they take their fee right so it's not
it's not direct cash being given to the
democrats but it's funding
partly their their fundraising apparatus
yeah i mean take five percent of 100
million whatever that is
right i mean look look at look at uh
if you look at the the the fine print
act blue is the payment mechanism so
we're not saying it's going directly but
whatever akblue money makes off of per
transaction is going to the democratic
party's going to their act blue
i think it's another like pack or
something like that yeah yeah yeah well
so so
this is crazy a percentage of the money
goes to their operations or whatever
right they use it to fund their
operations but they also have some kind
of provision where
if the organization doesn't collect it
then they can disperse it
yes yes yes exactly yes i saw that too
that's in the fine print
that's exactly that's standard in a lot
of these contracts with these
fundraising
it makes sense to be to be fair it makes
sense yeah you can't just have money
floating around doing nothing right
with it you got to put it to work and
then you have to tell people you're
going to
right right yeah um but again you know
where's the money
this is this has been the problem with
the black community um
i'm not going to go ahead and slander
mount martin luther king like that on
tim cass
tim cool's podcast but i mean um
does that happen back in the day too
yeah man the whole the whole civil
rights movement was a
was a big publicity stunt what yeah
it kind of worked though didn't it yeah
it worked to destroy us
really why do you think integration was
infiltration
interesting integration was infiltration
i go to the school of thaddeus russell
renegade university
and um he's got he's got all the facts
laid out we we do a tuesday night class
about africa did you know that w.e.b the
boy never met a black person until he
was 20 years old i didn't know that
that's crazy
who is that he was frank w ebb the boy
you know one of them
old heads from like late
late 1800s early 1900s he lived to
a very old age but uh father is
socialist
um sociology uh black guy half but he's
mixed he's mixed
um but yeah you know uh the
integrationists really what happened was
the integrationists
wanted uh well let's talk about what the
independent people wanted independent
black folks said hey look there's money
coming to
from the government to white schools we
want money for our schools and
naacp and all those sellouts
came around and said look we'll fight
for your cause
if you agree to integrate and they said
we don't want to integrate we're
cool with our schools and they're like
nah we're not going to support you
unless you integrate so you know when
people talk about
they like to talk about tulsa and they
like to call it a massacre it's not a
massacre if you fight back
right so tulsa was not a massacre it was
definitely an attack on black property
and black businesses and black life
but we fought back and and tulsa
survived for 40 years after that attack
that was black wall street right black
wall street they called it what happened
yeah you know some white folks was a
little upset came down and started
acting rowdy
i think they were democrats weren't they
they were dixie currents dixiecrats yeah
yeah you know white liberals um so yeah
so they came down and
you know caused the fuss and they were
dropping bombs from airplanes
yeah it was it got it got really serious
yeah but the point is
uh black wall street doesn't die until
integration
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you